make the case if you could uh for for
opposition to the extension
of the coronavirus regulations sure well
there's
there's several things being voted on
today so in terms of the road map
uh which the government wants to have
ends by the 21st of june
um but we think that could safely go
more quickly
than that um but the biggest problem
today is the extension of some very
significant draconian powers in the
coronavirus act
which the government doesn't want to
extend to june it actually wants to
extend
all the way until october and these are
quite significant powers their powers
for example for the police to be able to
detain people
indefinitely and to continue having
powers to
uh shut down events and so forth all the
way through to october
and i haven't heard a single good answer
about why the government wishes to do
that given that the prime minister has
said he wants to be out of all of our
legal restrictions by june
just just on that point though do you mr
harper not not try the police would have
a degree of discretion
in those circumstances to to use the
powers to decide when to
and when not to do do you not trust the
police with that discretion
well it's interesting that you say that
at the moment the powers in the
coronavirus act that have been used my
understanding is that
in every case they've been used the
courts have ruled that they've been used
unlawfully so actually these are very
significant powers which i don't think
should exist the government's own
explanatory details to that bill says
these are extraordinary measures
that should only exist in very uh
emergency circumstances
and and we're supposed to be out of this
emergency by due
according to the government and i said i
haven't heard any reason why these
significant powers should be extended
until october uh so i will be voting
against those
uh today because i haven't heard any
credible reason why we shouldn't
um and clearly they're going to pass the
labour party
isn't uh it's not even on the the field
of play on this very important issue is
not asking the government any
questions of any difficulty um and
they're not even shouting from the
sidelines so
but some of us have to ask reasonable
questions about what's going on
um but uh clearly the measures will pass
today because the labour party is going
to support them but
i think these questions need to be asked
and ministers need to be pressed to give
good answers about why they want to
extend these powers
all the way until october when the prime
minister says he wants to be out of
uh these problems uh by the middle of
june
what do you then make of of the proposal
mr harper to
offer access or to offer landlords the
opportunity to restrict access
to their venues on the basis of either a
negative uh
covert 19 test or indeed vaccination i i
suspect that you're not desperately
pleased with that no well i mean i
actually agree with the prime minister
that is the prime minister of
february when he said that he didn't
think there was a
case for expecting people to show papers
to go to the pub
and he said they were very significant
and he said there were very significant
problems
uh with um ethical moral
questions about this issue and i've
heard
some pub heads of pub chains this
morning set out some of those
significant problems
that the key way that we're going to
deal with this issue is by vaccinating
people and we've already
almost finished vaccinating with their
first doses
the top nine groups who are most
vulnerable who account for 99
of those who died from covid and over 80
of the hospitalizations
that's how we get out of this and of
course the government has much to
celebrate here it's
had a fantastic roll out of vaccination
it did a great job in procuring vaccines
uh at the original point of this and
we're well ahead of any significant
major
country uh in the world and i think
that's something that the government
should celebrate
and take full advantage of it mr harper
we do have to let you go but i just want
to squeeze on one final question we have
seen
huge amounts of state borrowing from
this from this conservative government
huge amount
amounts of state spending and sectoral
support we are seeing
from your perspective civil liberties
are being run
ridden roughshod over i'm just wondering
are you still happy being a conservative
these days yes i am i
i think the government took exactly the
right measures to use its economic
support
to protect jobs and livelihoods through
this emergency
situation of course it's going to mean
that over time
we're going to have to rebuild the
public finances and put them back but
actually i've been incredibly proud of
what the chancellor has been doing
in making sure the state uses its its
borrowing powers and its emergency
powers
to stand behind people and protect
families
say protect jobs and protect livelihoods
and help people get through this
pandemic
and get out of the other side in in
reasonable economic shape i think that's
been the right thing to do
and i'm very proud of being part of a
party that's delivered that support for
people across the country